Fühlen Sie sich bereit
für den grossen Schritt?
Darf ich Ihnen
den Kugelschreiber überreichen?
* Dynamische Musik *
Irgendwann ist es Zeit, loszulassen.
Irgendwann beginnt etwas Neues.
Das sind vier Geschichten
rund um Menschen,
die sich
ans Abenteuer Nachfolge wagen.
Einer davon ist Hausarzt Martin Sigg.
Vielen Dank.
- Alles Gute! Ihnen auch.
Nach langer Suche hat er einen
Nachfolger für seine Praxis gefunden.
Ich habe schon gesagt: Die Kulisse
ist fast so schön wie in der Praxis.
Freude und Erleichterung
auch bei der Gemeinde Hergiswil
und allen, die an der Nachfolgersuche
beteiligt waren.
Zum Wohl, Martin!
- Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Im Moment kann ich die Situation
noch nicht ganz realisieren.
Es ist eine spannende Situation.
Ich war bisher noch nie
in einer solchen Situation
mit so wichtigen Persönlichkeiten
an so einem schönen Ort
zu einer Praxisübernahme.
Ich denke, die nächsten Tage
werde ich es realisieren.
Es wird sich setzen. Ich bin
gespannt. Aber es geht gut, danke.
So. Jetzt ist gut.
Wir haben es überstanden.
- Wir sind alle erleichtert.
Herr Walker, alles Gute!
- Es war mir eine Freude.
Ja, mir auch.
Es  i s t  mir eine Freude.
Es war nicht, es ist.
- Und es bleibt noch eine Freude.
Drei Jahre hat Martin Sigg
auf diesen Moment gewartet.
Hervorragend.
Mir geht es
viel besser als am Morgen.
Ich fühle mich
relaxt, entspannt und gut.
Ich denke, wir können es geniessen,
uns zurücklehnen und denken:
"Ja."
Wir sind beruhigt, zu wissen,
dass jemand Tolles hier ist.
Er wird das gut machen.
Nach mehr als 35 Jahren kann
Martin Sigg mit 70 in Rente gehen.
Auf dem Hof im Emmental in Röthenbach
steht bei Wielands
die erste grosse Hochzeit bevor.
Geht es bei dir?
- Ja, danke. Es geht recht gut.
Die Stühle sind jetzt dann bereit.
Super. Sehr gut.
Ich packe noch ein wenig aus.
Ist das gut?
Ja. Sehr gerne.
Und du schaust zu, nicht wahr?
Salome
wird von ihrem Vater unterstützt.
Mami räumt Kartons weg.
Hey, na du? Hoi.
Wir erwarten grössere Events.
Wir haben dieses Jahr noch vier
Hochzeiten, Hochzeitsaperos.
Und da brauchen wir die Sitzplätze.
Wir werden Hochzeiten
mit 250-300 Personen haben.
Aber auch kleine
mit 100-150 Personen.
Thom und Salome
sind seit knapp einem halben Jahr
Besitzer dieses Hofs in Röthenbach -
ein Milchwirtschaftsbetrieb
mit 14 Milchkühen.
Zusätzlich
setzen sie auf Agrotourismus
und haben
unter dem Label Wielandleben
ein kleines Unternehmen aufgebaut.
Oben müssen wir
noch ein wenig rausnehmen.
Wir haben uns gut eingelebt.
Es braucht zwar noch Zeit,
bis alles gemacht ist,
aber bis jetzt geht es sehr gut.
Wir sind zufrieden,
wie es vorwärtsgeht.
Dafür, dass wir
noch nicht länger hier sind,
sieht es schon recht gut aus.
Hier noch ins Loch hinein.
Mit dabei auch Peter und Andreas,
ihre Mitbewohner
des betreuten Wohnens,
das sie auch noch anbieten.
Hier haben 150 Leute sitzend Platz.
Krass!
Es liegt doch noch
in unserer Verantwortung,
wie viele Leute wir annehmen
oder nicht.
Bei dieser Grösse der Terrasse
können wir auch mal Nein sagen,
wenn es nicht mehr geht,
sodass wir das Leben lang Kraft
für dieses Projekt haben.
In Ostermundigen
ist die neue Pfarrerin Aline Berger
unterwegs mit 33 Kindern.
Es geht noch.
Ich habe noch zwei Helferinnen.
Sie sind es sich gewohnt.
Es sind keine Dorfkinder, die sonst
nie ein Auto oder einen Bus sehen.
Aber ich bin schon froh, dass
die anderen beiden auch schauen.
Zu ihren Aufgaben gehört die KUW -
die Kirchliche Unterweisung.
Also. Alle aussteigen!
Heute ist sie auf dem Weg
ins Historische Museum,
das am Berner Münster vorbeiführt.
Kommt noch schnell!
Das ist ganz berühmt in Bern.
Wer weiss, was das ist?
Wart ihr schon mal hier?
- (Viele Kinder) Ja!
Viele waren schon hier.
Und das hier ist ganz berühmt
in Bern: die Münsterpforte.
Auf der rechten Seite sieht man
die Hölle und links den Himmel.
Die Leute haben sich früher wirklich
vorgestellt, dass es so ist:
Wenn man tot ist, kommt man
an den einen oder anderen Ort.
Das machte den Leuten auch Angst.
Sie dachten wirklich, dass sie
vielleicht in die Hölle kommen.
Und heute ... Ich glaube nicht
an eine solche Hölle nach dem Tod.
Vielleicht ist der Krieg ...
In unserer Welt
gibt es schon eine Art Hölle.
Es gibt Leute, die "durch die Hölle
gehen", die Schlimmes erleben.
Aber keinen Ort,
wo man für immer hinkommt.
Aline arbeitet biblische Themen
aktuell auf.
Mit den Schülern
hat sie den Auszug des Volkes Israel
aus Ägypten behandelt
und besucht im Historischen Museum
Bern eine Ausstellung zu Ägypten
und zum Thema Flucht.
Sie nannten ihn "den Velopfarrer",
als er noch im Dienst war:
Peter Christen, Vorgänger von Aline.
Er war 27 Jahre lang
Pfarrer mit Leib und Seele.
Seit fast einem Jahr
ist er pensioniert.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Guten Tag.
- Hoi.
Er ist da dran.
Und sonst ist alles gut?
- Sonst ist alles gut.
Gut.
- Gute Fahrt! - Merci.
Jetzt hat er
eine neue Aufgabe gefunden.
Er fährt zwei Tage pro Monat Taxi
für Menschen mit Behinderung.
Es ist wohl schon der stärkste Motor
der ganzen Sache.
Es befriedigt mich.
Ich darf ihnen etwas geben.
Das dünkte mich im Pfarramt
stets schwierig.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
ich sei derart ausgelastet,
dass ich keine Kapazitäten
für ehrenamtliche Arbeit habe.
Und dann sagte ich mir: "Jetzt
möchte ich in irgendeiner Form
etwas in diese Richtung machen."
In der Kirchgemeinde
betreut er nach wie vor
die Weiterbildung im Computerbereich.
Zuerst war es wahnsinnig schön.
Einfach Ferien.
Ich genoss es.
Dann kam langsam das,
von dem ich sagte, ich wolle es:
Langeweile.
Nicht schon am Morgen wissen,
was alles sein muss oder darf.
Es gab Momente,
in denen es mich irritierte.
Aber je länger je mehr
geniesse ich die Möglichkeit,
dass nicht alles
von vorne bis hinten verplant ist.
Wollen Sie sich bei mir einhängen?
* Er lacht. *
Auf Wiedersehen, Herr Brüllhart.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Gleichfalls.
Jetzt machen wir
eine schöne Spazierfahrt.
Ja.
Sie werden staunen.
Die wunderschönen grünen ...
Ja. Die sind so schön.
- Nicht wahr?
Das ist wirklich sehr schön.
- Ja.
Ich wende gleich, damit Sie
die Berge betrachten können.
Jetzt sieht man sie langsam.
- Schauen Sie sich diese Berge an!
Es ist unerhört schön.
* Beschauliche Musik *
In Hergiswil
hat der neue Hausarzt Marcelo Walker
seine erste Arbeitswoche.
Offiziell übernimmt er die Praxis
erst in vier Monaten.
Bis dann ist er noch angestellt
und wird den Patienten von Martin
Sigg als Nachfolger vorgestellt.
Ich wollte dir
Herr Blättler vorstellen.
Schön. Hallo.
- Herr Walker. Herr Blättler.
Mein Nachfolger.
- Freut mich.
Ich hoffe,
du findest dich gut mit ihm zurecht.
Sie sassen so manches Jahrzehnt
hier drin. - Genau. Ja. 35 Jahre.
Ein langjähriger Patient.
- Ja.
Eine schöne Sache.
Danke fürs Vorstellen.
- Gern geschehen.
Geh wieder zum anderen Patienten,
sonst ärgert sich die Dame!
Okay. Alles Gute.
Ich bin sicher bis Mitte Juli hier.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin
angekommen. Das habe ich gesucht.
Ich habe ein sehr gutes Gefühl
mit ihm. Das muss ich sagen.
Es ist sehr vielversprechend.
Auch die Rückmeldungen -
obwohl sie noch ganz frisch sind -
sind sehr gut.
Ich habe ihn
im Pflegeheim oben vorgestellt.
Ein Kollege hat mir schon
geschrieben, er sei erfreut.
Ich habe gestern
die E-Mail erhalten.
Er sei im Pflegeheim gut angekommen,
sei sehr gerühmt und
als sympathisch empfunden worden.
Er hat geschrieben: "Das ist gut für
dich, für ihn und auch für mich."
"Und Hergiswil."
Kann man sagen, dass die Schmerzen
seit drei Wochen zunehmend sind?
Marcelo Walker kommt
aus einer Ärztefamilie in Hamburg.
Vor drei Wochen haben Sie sich
den grossen Zeh gestossen.
Ja.
- Schauen wir uns das noch mal an!
Er ist Facharzt für innere Medizin,
hat einen Teil seiner Ausbildung
in der Schweiz absolviert
und zwei Jahre lang in einer
Gruppenpraxis in Kriens gearbeitet.
Gut. Machen wir.
- Super. Danke.
Bis gleich. Bis später, ja?
Die ersten Tage
sind natürlich spannend.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es ein sehr schöner Start war.
Ich wurde sehr herzlich begrüsst.
Ich habe zu Beginn eine schöne Blume
geschenkt bekommen.
Wir haben auch schon gemeinsam
gemütlich gegessen.
Das war ein sehr schöner Start.
Jetzt ist es gerade
ein bisschen hektisch.
Mehrere Patienten
sind gleichzeitig gekommen.
Aber die Damen
organisieren das sehr gut.
Und die Patienten sind verständnis-
voll. Das funktioniert gut.
Marcelo Walker teilt in den nächsten
Monaten die Arbeit mit Martin Sigg.
Er arbeitet eng mit ihm zusammen,
sodass eine saubere Übergabe
gewährleistet ist.
Ich stelle den Stuhl dazu.
Ich wollte ganz kurz noch
Ihre Meinung dazu.
Herr Zibung hat seit ein paar Tagen
eine zunehmende Schwellung.
(Martin Sigg)
Es ist bis nach vorne geschwollen.
Und da hinten.
(Marcelo Walker) Vielleicht
ein beginnender Abszess.
Es ist vor dem Kieferwinkel.
Also Parotitis ...
Eine reine Parotitis
wäre hier hinten und hier.
Ganz ehrlich:
Ich würde das einem ORL-Arzt zeigen.
Ich würde ihn weiter verweisen.
- Das dachte ich mir auch.
(Martin Sigg) Relativ dringlich.
(Marcelo Walker)
Bevor die Entzündungswerte steigen
und sich ein Abszess entwickelt.
- Sonst keine geschwollenen Drüsen?
Submandibulär.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich wird man
ein MRI des Schädels machen müssen.
Um die Weichteile anzuschauen.
Das ist noch spezifischer.
Der Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Arzt muss das
weiter abklären. Ganz sicher.
Ist das okay für Sie? Dann
nimmt er das wieder an die Hand.
Vielen Dank.
- Alles Gute! Gern geschehen.
- Alles Gute!
Kommen Sie mit!
Marcelo Walker
übernimmt eine gut laufende Praxis
mit über 5'000 Patienten.
In Zukunft sucht er einen
zusätzlichen Arzt, der ihn entlastet.
Ich bin gespannt.
Für mich ist es ein Abenteuer.
Ich kann noch nicht überblicken,
was alles auf mich zukommt.
Ich weiss,
dass es viel Organisation ist.
Ein gewisses Organisationstalent
gehört dazu.
Aber ich bin optimistisch. Ich
schaue einfach mal, wie es kommt.
Ist er beschäftigt?
- Ja. Bei einem Patienten.
Wenn er fertig ist,
stelle ich ihn Frau Baumann vor.
In Röthenbach
bereiten Salome und Thom
alles
für die erste grosse Hochzeit vor.
Sie erwarten 150 Gäste.
Ich stelle den Bartisch
dort beim weissen Bartisch hin.
Dann haben wir zwei dort.
Vielleicht könnte man vor dem Haus
auch noch zwei hinstellen. - Nein.
Die Leute sollen ja
auf die Terrasse gehen. - Stimmt.
(Thom) Hier kann man sie gut
hinstellen. Hier unten auch.
(Salome) Ja.
Tipptopp.
Eine schön gerade Terrasse.
Ich bin gar nicht nervös.
Ich freue mich auf die Leute.
(Salome) Ich freue mich auch.
Das Wetter sieht gut aus.
- Es ist etwas bewölkt.
Am Nachmittag könnte es regnen.
Damit muss man rechnen.
Wenn es regnet,
ist es nicht so tragisch.
Wir haben genügend Möglichkeiten,
drin zu sein.
Es ist beides gut.
Ja.
Die Aussicht ist natürlich schön.
Wenn das Wetter so bleibt,
ist die Aussicht bombastisch. - Ja.
Lydia und Ernst
sind ins Nachbarhaus umgezogen.
Über 30 Jahre lang
haben Sie den Hof bewirtschaftet.
Weil es Ernst immer schlechter ging,
mussten sie verkaufen.
Wenn Ernst nicht gerade zu Hause
handwerkt, arbeitet er auswärts.
Wir haben immer
gemeinsam gearbeitet.
Das gefiel mir. Hand in Hand.
Wir waren ein gutes Team,
nicht wahr?
Ja.
Das war schön.
Die Arbeit
war für mich nie ein Müssen.
Ohne dich hätte ich schon vor
zehn oder 15 Jahren aufhören müssen.
Aber wir wollen jetzt
auch anderes machen.
Schritt um Schritt.
Wir möchten uns daran gewöhnen.
Es ist ein Prozess.
Dass ...
* Bohrlärm *
Die Arbeit auswärts ist für mich
sicher eine Veränderung.
Das ist anders,
als ständig hier zu sein.
Es gibt jetzt einfach Tage,
in denen ich fix auswärts arbeite
und nicht hier bin.
Das ist sicher eine Umstellung.
Aber es ist auch schön.
Ich habe keine schwere Arbeit mehr.
Es ist schon eine Erleichterung.
Als Bauer
könnte ich nicht mehr arbeiten.
* Bohrlärm *
Vormittags
haben wir jeweils gemolken.
Das würde heute nicht mehr so gut
gehen: hinsetzen, aufstehen ...
* Vorbeifahrendes Auto *
Aufstehen, hinsetzen - ich könnte
alleine nicht mehr melken.
Das könnte ich nicht mehr.
Ich komme mir schon bald vor
wie ein 75-jähriger Mann.
* Bohrgeräusch *
Es ist richtig, wie es ist.
Und trotzdem
muss man sich daran gewöhnen.
Wir haben den Hof
31 Jahre lang bewirtschaftet.
Das ist nicht einfach fertig und ...
Es ist ein Prozess.
* Dynamische Musik *
Ihr habt euch
im Zusammenhang mit Ägypten
auch mit dem Volk Israel,
mit der Bibel beschäftigt.
Dazu stehen wir auf.
Im Historischen Museum Bern
will Aline den Kindern
die Kultur von Ägypten näherbringen.
Welche Figuren aus der Bibel
kommen euch in den Sinn,
die in Ägypten waren?
(Mädchen) Moses.
- Genau. Moses.
Der führt sie
aus der Sklaverei heraus.
(Mädchen) Ist hier alles echt?
Alles, was ihr hier seht, ist echt.
Wichtig ist ...
Wir sammeln uns jetzt hier herum.
Das ist das Kinn.
(Junge) Hirn?
- Das Kinn.
Hier ist der Nasen- und Mundbereich
mit den Zähnen.
(Kinder) Igitt!
In Röthenbach sind die ersten Gäste
und das Hochzeitspaar eingetroffen.
Hast du jemanden,
der dir das Kleid hält,
damit du am Boden
nicht hängen bleibst? - Nein.
Am Holz.
- Können wir das mal testen?
Nein, doch nicht. Sonst sind
die Blüten alle vorne bei mir.
Ähm ... - Du kannst
das Kleid ja selber anheben.
Ich kann meiner Trauzeugin sagen,
sie soll mitlaufen.
Sie soll hinterherlaufen.
Lass es mal runter!
Es ist keine lange Schleppe.
(Bräutigam) Die ist dann schwarz.
- Ja. Hier ist es schwarz.
Das geht schon.
- Es ist keine grosse Schleppe.
Du stehst dann ja vorne, oder?
- (Bräutigam) Ja.
Die Trauung
findet auf der Heubühne statt.
Hochzeiten und Events sind im Moment
die Haupteinnahmequelle der Wielands.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik mit Gesang *
Die zweite Schale mit Gemüsedip
können wir noch nach oben nehmen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik mit Gesang *
Bei ihnen ist alles frisch
vom eigenen Hof und aus der Region.
* Dialog
wird von der Musik übertönt. *
Ich gönne es ihnen,
ein schönes Fest zu haben.
Ja. Das sieht
nach einer grossen Sache aus.
Ja.
* Dramatische Orgelmusik *
Der Auszug des israelischen Volks
aus Ägypten war auch eine Flucht.
Manchmal müsst ihr lesen,
weil es Untertitel hat.
Ihr seht es dann schon.
In Absprache mit der Kirchgemeinde
und dem Historischen Museum Bern
hat Aline beschlossen,
mit den Kindern
in die Wanderausstellung "Flucht"
zu gehen,
wo das Thema mit aktuellen Bildern
aufgearbeitet wird.
* Arabischer Sprechgesang *
* Explosion *
(Junge) What the heck!
Ich weiss nicht,
ob sie mit ihren Eltern
die Nachrichten hören oder schauen.
Es liefert sicher die Bilder zu dem,
worüber gesprochen wird.
Heute Morgen merkte ich, dass
bei einigen Parolen umgingen wie:
"Warum kommen diese Flüchtlinge
überhaupt?"
Eher bei den Jungs.
Und jetzt sehen sie,
was das für Leute sind.
Um die Bilder einzuordnen,
ist es Aline wichtig,
dass sie das, was sie gesehen haben,
gemeinsam mit den Kindern bespricht.
Also. Ihr habt diesen Film gesehen.
Jemand hat gefragt, ob es echt ist.
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
(Junge) Warum filmt man
in diesem Moment noch?
Ja. Was meint ihr?
Warum sind dort Leute mit Kameras?
Man will das dokumentieren.
Dass man weiss, wie schlimm es ist
und wie gut wir es haben.
Und dass man vielleicht hilft.
- Genau.
Dass man sieht, was dort passiert.
Ich höre oft Radio.
Und dort klingt es nur halb
so schlimm als wenn man es sieht.
Vielleicht
helfen solche Bilder auch,
Verständnis zu haben für
die Flüchtlinge, die hierherkommen.
Die wollen uns nicht einfach
unser schönes Land wegnehmen.
Sie haben es wirklich schwierig
und suchen Sicherheit.
Sara?
Wir müssen jeden Tag,
an dem wir leben,
Freude haben und glücklich sein.
Meinst du, wenn man sieht,
wie gut wir es eigentlich haben?
Ja.
* Dynamische Musik *
Hausarzt Martin Sigg war es immer ein
Anliegen, dass auch sein Nachfolger
die Patienten
im Alters- und Pflegeheim besucht
und v.a. den Menschen mit seiner
Geschichte in den Mittelpunkt stellt.
Eine ältere Dame, die ich schon
seit 30 Jahre als Patientin kenne.
Eine Ungarin, die vor langer Zeit
vor dem Krieg geflohen ist.
Guten Tag, Herr Doktor Sigg.
Grüezi, Frau Szabo.
Das ist der Herr Doktor Walker.
Frau Szabo.
Es ging mir hauptsächlich darum,
dass ich Ihnen meinen Nachfolger ...
Zuerst muss ich Ihnen noch herzlich
für Ihre Osterkarte danken.
Ist gut, Herr Doktor.
- Sind Sie der neue Herr Doktor?
Ja.
- Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Sie sagten doch, Sie wollen
einen jungen, hübschen Mann.
Sie waren aber auch so.
- Das war mal, ja.
Wenn wir zurückdenken ...
Über 30 Jahre!
Als wir frisch angekommen sind,
kamen wir zu Ihnen.
Vor wie vielen Jahren war das?
- 35.
35 Jahre.
Wir waren noch jung, als wir
den Herrn Doktor kennenlernten -
mein Mann und ich.
Sie blieben der Praxis
über Jahrzehnte treu? - Ja.
Jetzt naht der Abschied.
Ich komme schon noch mal,
um mich zu verabschieden.
Aber im Moment bin ich noch da.
- Ja, das weiss ich.
Und wann beginnen Sie, Herr Doktor?
Ich habe diese Woche
schon angefangen. - Ach so.
Ich habe das Glück,
dass ich mit Doktor Sigg
noch zusammenarbeiten kann,
bis es dann passt.
Und dann?
- (Martin Sigg) Was ich dann mache?
Ich geniesse das Leben.
- Ja, sicher.
Die Freizeit geniessen.
Herr Doktor, ich kann nicht sagen,
dass ich gerne gegangen bin,
aber ich gönne es Ihnen
selbstverständlich.
Ich hatte einen so guten Job,
dass ich nicht gerne
in Rente gegangen bin.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass das ein anderer Beruf ist,
ein strenger Beruf.
Und sowieso ...
Sie werden ja auch schon 70.
Ja.
- Sie haben ja schon überzogen.
Ja, ich habe ein wenig überzogen.
- Ja, ja.
Herr Doktor, es hat mich gefreut,
Sie kennenzulernen.
Ebenso.
- Gute Zusammenarbeit!
Ebenso. Ja. Schön.
Adieu, Frau Szabo.
- Alles Gute!
Er kriegt einen Kuss von mir.
- Ich kriege einen Kuss.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
- Alles Gute!
Vielen Dank für Ihren Besuch.
Schön.
Ich bin gespannt. Ja.
Darf man als Arzt so was überhaupt
entgegennehmen? - Doch, doch.
Kleinigkeiten.
- Das darfst du alles.
Früher haben die Leute ja
mit Speckseiten ihre Sachen bezahlt.
35 Jahre lange war Martin Sigg
für seine Patienten da.
Mein Kollege
hat mich schon davor gewarnt.
Man sieht erst, wenn man aufhört,
was man den Patienten bedeutet hat.
Vieles ist selbstverständlich
oder man spricht nicht darüber.
Aber die berührenden Momente
kommen erst, wenn man aufhört.
Oder bei einem Wechsel.
Oder bei einem Schicksalsschlag.
Dann spürt man die Anerkennung.
Oder wenn ein Schicksalsschlag
überständen ist.
Ich denke schon. Ich lebe
auch ein bisschen von meinem Ego.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Aspekt,
der mir sicher fehlen wird.
Es ist auch
wie ein Sprung ins kalte Wasser.
Man kann vorher nicht wissen,
wie es wird.
Trotzdem
macht es das gerade interessant.
Man wird dann sicherlich
jeden Tag neue Dinge erleben
und neue Gesichter kennenlernen.
Sich dann
in der Situation zu finden,
dass man an einem Ort angekommen
ist, ist eine ganz neue Dimension.
Aber ich glaube, es ist auch gut,
im Leben einen Ort zu finden,
an dem man bleiben kann,
an dem man sich wohlfühlt.
Da gibt es wohl auch schlechtere
Orte auf der Welt als Hergiswil.
Da fällt die Entscheidung leicht,
zu bleiben.
Martin Sigg
arbeitet noch so lange in der Praxis,
bis Marcelo Walker
einen zusätzlichen Arzt gefunden hat.
* Gefühlvoller Gesang *
Die erste Hochzeit auf dem Hof
der Wielands ist ein Erfolg.
Sie sind
auf ihrem Bauernhof angekommen
und verbinden
die traditionelle Landwirtschaft
mit ihren Ideen des Agrotourismus
und mit Events.
Es passt alles durchs Band
bis zum Abend hin.
Das freut mich.
- Wir haben den gleichen Geschmack.
Es ist genial. Wir werden uns
dann noch persönlich bedanken.
Wir möchten euch das noch übergeben.
Vielleicht habt ihr ja morgen früh
Zeit, noch etwas Brot zu essen.
Und sonst könnt ihr es
als Erinnerung behalten.
Das nehmen wir gleich mit.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke auch.
Es war super. Vielen Dank.
- Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank euch.
Thom und Salome leben ihren Traum -
gemeinsam mit Lilou
Peter und Andreas.
Wir haben uns sehr gut eingelebt.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
wir sind schon viel länger hier.
Und trotzdem ist es krass,
was wir in diesem halben Jahr
schon machen konnten - welche Events
wir hier schon feiern durften.
Das ist sehr cool.
Wir durften viel erleben.
Es kommt mir länger vor.
Ja, das ist so.
Ich glaube, das ist das Wichtigste:
Wenn man mit Herz und Freude
dabei ist, macht man es auch.
Dann ist es wie ein Hobby.
Man räumt die Bühne als Hobby raus.
Man geht dafür nicht joggen oder so.
Ziel ist, dass wir einige grosse
Events pro Jahr machen können -
gemeinsam mit den Bewohnern.
Das ist das längerfristige Ziel.
Auch Aline hat in Ostermundigen
ihre Rolle gefunden.
Hallo.
Willkommen.
Ca va?
Als Frau Pfarrerin mit Freund Jan.
So. Hattest du einen guten Tag?
Ja. Schön, aber etwas anstrengend.
Es waren 33 Kinder.
Und nur drei Leiterinnen.
Nur drei Leiterinnen?
- Ja.
Gut.
Im Grossen und Ganzen
war es nicht so schwierig.
Aber ich glaube, das hat
viel mit Ostermundigen zu tun.
Es ist eine Agglomerationsgemeinde.
In einem kleinen Dorf
wäre das anders.
Einige Leute
erzählen mir von Pesche.
Manche sagen auch, sie hätten ihn
gerne für die Beerdigung gehabt,
weil er auch schon
getauft und konfirmiert hat.
Aber es ist ...
Sie sind dann auch glücklich damit,
wie ich es mache.
Ich glaube auch ...
... dass ich
Ähnlichkeiten mit Pesche habe.
Die offene Art. Ich kann leicht
auf Menschen zugehen.
Das ...
Auch wenn wir unterschiedlich sind.
Aber es freut sie sicher, dass
wieder so eine offene Person da ist.
* Rockige Klänge *
Und wie sieht es bei Markus
im ComeBack in Bern aus -
dem Laden mit speziellen Hemden
für spezielle Kundschaft?
Ja ...
Wo stehe ich?
Im Moment gibt es nichts Konkretes.
Es sieht nicht danach aus, als würde
es bald klappen. Wir suchen weiter.
Konkret nicht.
Es waren Typen um die 40.
Zwei haben sich hier erkundigt.
Sie wollten alles
bis auf die Buchhaltung erkundigen.
Sie waren um die 40.
Ja.
Einer wollte einen Versand machen
und kam mit ausgedruckten Plänen.
Ich riet ihm sofort davon ab
und sagte, das funktioniere nicht.
Dann hatte er das Gefühl,
ich behalte den Laden und er
könne gemeinsam mit mir verkaufen.
So geht es einfach nicht.
Ich will jemanden, der den Laden
so übernimmt, Freude daran hat
und ihn weiterführt.
Der ganze Kundenstamm ist ja da.
Er erhält am Abend den Schlüssel
und kann am Morgen aufschliessen.
Das ComeBack ist für Markus
mehr als nur ein Hemdenladen.
Es ist eine Passion,
ein Teil seines Lebens.
Seine Liebe für Details und
seine Kunden machen das ComeBack aus.
Schauen Sie hier!
Hier ist je ein Muster drin.
Vielleicht ist kein L da,
aber dann könnte ich eines holen.
Das ist noch eines,
das infrage kommt.
Das ist auch 30.
Auch ein Restposten.
Wenn es ihm so viel bedeutet,
dass es so weitergeführt wird,
ist es nicht einfach,
jemanden zu finden.
Jemanden, der ...
Ich habe auch ein Geschäft. Und
das möchte ich auch nicht abgeben.
Aber ich kann es
noch 20 Jahre machen.
Aber ... Man merkt es, wenn man
sonst Hemden und Läden sieht ...
Da stecken viele Details drin.
Er kennt die Händler,
besucht sie, holt drei Stück ...
Je länger, je mehr
wollen Leute etwas haben,
das nicht noch zehn andere
in der Stadt tragen.
Wenn der Laden richtig geführt wird,
ist das nach wie vor zeitgemäss.
Ja. Danke.
Aber ist das ComeBack
noch das ComeBack,
wenn Markus nicht mehr da ist?
Merci.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Sie kommen wegen der Hemden.
An erster Stelle.
Aber ...
Ich sage immer: Mein Traum ist,
dass eine Frau übernimmt.
Das wäre mein Traum.
Eine Frau, die ein Flair dafür hat,
kann das sicher noch besser.
Davon bin ich überzeugt.
Mit Charme
die Männer hier zu bedienen ...
Ja. Seriös natürlich, aber ...
Das wäre für mich ...
Ich habe fast das Gefühl,
es passiert mal.
Sie kommen ganz sicher
an erster Stelle wegen der Hemden.
Und dann vielleicht
noch ein wenig meinetwegen, aber ...
* Gefühlvoller Song:
"Fingt ds Glück eim?" von Züri West *
Irgendwann einmal ist es Zeit,
loszulassen.
Irgendwann beginnt etwas Neues.
Das waren vier Geschichten
von Menschen,
die sich ans Abenteuer Nachfolge
gewagt haben.
# Irgendeinisch fingt ds Glück eim
irgendwo uf em e Parkplatz.
# U plötzlech
schmöckt's wieder wie daheim.
# Irgendeinisch fingt ds Glück eim.